[Music]
[Applause]
mike florio popular co-host of pro
football talk live he joins us on the
program let me start with the poll
question the underdog best chance to win
in the afc
i think it's the patriots bill belichick
single elimination all those playoff
games he's coached over the years and it
has to be a record that the bills and
the patriots for two teams to get
together three times in 40 days they had
two late regular season games patriots
won in buffalo on a cold and windy night
now it's not going to be as windy and
even if it is i think the bills have
figured out they need to unleash josh
allen it's not going to be easy for the
patriots but it's hard not to trust bill
belichick if you give me those three
options and you say which one wins and
we know that home teams have been
winning games like never before i'd have
to go with the patriots all the votes
are in for all the honors
coach of the year mvp all of that's been
tabulated here
uh who's your coach of the year
well i don't have one of the votes
so we do our own awards and at pft i
consulted with my staff and i'm not
being sarcastic because i wasn't sure
which way i was going to go with coach
of the year but they persuaded me that
it should be mike variable and when you
consider that they set a record in week
12 they set the record for the number of
total players used they didn't have
derek henry the best player on their
team for more than half of the season
and they still got the number one seed
in a top-heavy afc you know i was
thinking matt lafleur
until we really sat down and talked it
through and and you know rich versace
what he did was so special but
it's it's a tough year but i think
frable by a nose over lafleur
yeah i was wondering about belichick
with it was like last year he did one of
his best coaching jobs uh this year i
expected them to make the playoffs but i
i don't know
how do you differentiate when you're the
greatest coach of all time it's like
chuck noll i don't think everyone coach
of the year you know the the great
coaches or the guys who are really
successful normally don't win coach of
the year why is that well because the
coach of the year is kind of loosely
determined by how
far you exceed the expectations that
were loosely out there going into the
season so if there's a team that's just
supposed to be complete and total crap
and they make the playoffs all of a
sudden that coach is a viable candidate
for coach of the year the bar is always
high for the patriots so it's very
difficult for bill belichick to exceed
that bar high enough that it stands out
over somebody who takes a team from
worst to first like a zach taylor who
should get some consideration or of
rabel who did something special without
his best player but you know dan we also
do executive year that's not one of the
official associated press nfl awards
sporting news for whatever reason is
still the officially recognized
executive of the year that's the one
that people pay attention to i don't
know why i don't even think they still
make sporting news but that's another
issue altogether we made belichick our
executive of the year because it's
always hand in hand what belichick does
as an executive either makes it harder
or easier for him as a coach
this year what they did going all in
spending all that money when they had
the cap space that they had carefully
built in a year where other teams
weren't as competitive
because of the
the drop in the salary cap due to the
pandemic and they they got mac jones
when maybe the 49ers really did want him
with the third overall pick and they
ultimately didn't take him and it just
worked out well that they have the
talent they need to be as competitive as
they were so he's executive of the year
not coach of the year but executive of
the year who's worst executive of the
year
well i don't know
dave gellerman has already been fired
although although you know
the the
the reality is and i think one of the
things we learn every year at this time
as the bad teams
dump coaches and general managers and
they make their owners available to
speak to the media you start to get an
idea of why bad teams stay bad
and why they can't get out of their own
way i got some strong feelings about the
giants for example and i think the
mara family is way too involved
in the management of that team from a
personnel standpoint and they're so
involved that they don't even realize
how involved they are
but there's a reason this team has been
to the playoffs once in the last decade
there's a reason this team has won
uh yeah yeah one playoff appearance no
playoff victory since their last super
bowl win it's stunning how far they've
fallen and i feel like they're in
quicksand and the harder they try to get
out the deeper they sink and i think at
this point i got the vibe from
the mayora press conference yesterday i
don't think they know what to do
now they're not going to admit that but
just i don't think they know what to do
and unless they're willing to completely
step aside from the personnel side of
the giants
i don't know that a general manager who
has real options
should want to go step into that job
well they fired joe judge which they had
to do i was told that
on monday that if you don't fire joe
judge you're going to limit the number
of candidates to become a general
manager there but i look at stephen ross
in miami it doesn't feel like he
knows what he's doing you have the bears
the mccaskey family it doesn't feel like
they know what they're doing right now
um and for different reasons for
different reasons with ross this is very
simple and there's a sweet spot i'm not
big into owners meddling
into what their team does
unless you're going to give yourself the
title like jerry jones did 32 years ago
and 32 years later he's the general
manager of the team
but i think the owner needs to live and
work
in the facility in the building in the
town where his team is you need to have
that presence every day the owners in
the building have robert craft and
robert craft isn't meddling with the
patriots but his base of operations is
gillette stadium i think if you're going
to buy an nfl team you need to make that
commitment that where the team does
business you do your business you need
to be there because when stephen ross
barnes storms in and he's watching the
game in the luxury suite and he's got
people from the front office whispering
to him and the coach can't defend
himself and there's any type of
dysfunction in the organization when the
boss isn't there who's getting thrown
under the bus it's the guy who doesn't
have a voice
whispering into the boss's ear the one
day a week that he happens to be in town
and with the bears it's a different
issue altogether but with with stephen
ross he should either commit to that
team completely move to south florida
show up every day or just sell the team
to someone who will is mike florio pro
football talk live co-host with chris
sims uh the jim harbaugh situation it
seems like he's enjoying this because it
felt like last year he was holding on
for dear life take a pay cut now all of
a sudden hey you got blown out by
georgia but so what
um
you know now you got teams reportedly
interested in him has anybody
interviewed jim harbaugh yet in the nfl
those types of interviews can happen
without anyone knowing the reason that
we see these reports over and over again
this week that
the vikings requested permission to
speak to this person the bears requested
permission to speak to that person if
it's somebody who's currently employed
by one of the other teams there's a
piece of paper that makes it to the
league office that then gets leaked to
reporters they have on the payroll or
others that that this interview is going
to happen if it's not somebody who's
currently employed by another team
there's no obligation
to let it be known to the league office
that you're talking to these people you
keep your internal records you need to
be able to show that you did a proper
search but you know somebody gave me the
idea over the weekend that maybe mark
davis has already quietly spoken to the
likes of jim harbaugh maybe jim caldwell
may you know others who are not
connected to other teams mark davis did
not take advantage of the two-week head
start
to speak to assistant coaches with other
teams he's focused so he said on the
postseason but there's a thought that
he's already talked to some people and
harbaugh could be talking off the grid
to
a lot of these teams and it used to be
that's how college coaches did it it was
the kiss of death to ever let anyone
know you were talking to an nfl team
because it was going to be used against
you in recruiting i remember when the
49ers hadn't hired dennis erickson in
2003. nobody even knew dennis erickson
was a candidate and he shouldn't have
been but nobody even knew he was a
candidate for the job and that's how it
used to be but now it's a little more
open and i think harbaugh is maybe at a
minimum at a minimum back channel
discussions about what he would be paid
and hey do your thing leverage michigan
that you took a 4 million pay cut this
is your chance to make it back go make
it back
uh antonio brown is not going to play
i guess the team is not going to be able
to pick him up
is he going to need surgery on his ankle
so therefore that would preclude him
from joining another another team
well this is the old dog chasing its
tail
analysis with antonio brown because we
saw him play against the jets and one of
the big arguments against the notion
that he said he was injured people
saying oh he ran off the field fine oh
look at this he was playing so i think
he could play at a level below 100
percent he was on that podcast last week
and they never really drilled down on
the question i would have you're not 100
percent but
if the chiefs would call you
and you're 85
and they'll take 85 percent antonio
brown over 100 byron pringle demarcus
robinson and josh gordon would you do
that and you know the fact that we
haven't heard
that surgery is scheduled it makes me
think
that he's just kind of waiting and
waiting just in case and hey look at it
this way if the chiefs win this weekend
and tyreke hill gets injured and he's
done for the rest of the playoffs and i
don't want to be accused of jinxing
anyone but that could happen he's got
that heel that he was hobbling around
with if all of a sudden tyreek kill's
gone and the chiefs are still alive how
do you not at least consider giving
antonio brown a call so you know i think
the smart move for him
is delay the surgery and i think he does
need surgery but i think if he had to
just like he did that day at metlife
stadium shoot it up with toradol go out
and play
are the colts stuck at quarterback
well they've given up a third round pick
and what will be a first round pick for
carson wentz now contractually could
they have some flexibility they didn't
take the gigantic cap charge on because
it was the eagles that made the big
upfront investment in carson wentz i
just think that they would be wise to
consider all options and when frank
reich was asked the question earlier
this week you know when you have a true
franchise quarterback and you're asked
any question about who you know what the
status of your quarterback is you know
if they would ask matt lafleur about
aaron rodgers status or bruce erin's
about tom brady says you'd laugh at it
the fact that carson wentz when his name
come up it wasn't laughed at by frank
wright that tells you they're gonna they
have to they have to because he was the
thing that held their offense back this
year
uh explain that tj watt is not the
all-time single season sack uh record
holder well the aborted snap the dreaded
aborted snap he thought it was a sack
early in the game against the ravens it
would have given him 22 and a half and
he would have broken it later in the
game but
because of the way that the play was
scored it was a snap that hit the rear
end of the center and it wasn't
technically a sack and they appealed to
the elias sports bureau and the elias
sports bureau denied the appeal so
there isn't an extra sack and and
there's a certain
irony to all of that because
the play that brett favre ran that
that's an aborted snap to me when
strahan got 22 and a half i was just
gonna ask you i was gonna ask you
which one is more of a sack in your
opinion
yeah neither
either
and hey tj watt did it in 15 games so
he's got that going for him and and you
know this whole debate about 17 versus
16 and should we put an asterisk on
these records it really doesn't matter
because the season is now 17 games the
nfl exercised its prerogative to expand
the season so the records are going to
reset and then it's going to expand to
18 and they're going to reset again
when do you think 18 rolls around
2030 at the latest but possibly sooner
even though the current labor deal with
the union
doesn't expire until the early part of
the next decade they can do a new deal
whenever they want and i think once they
fully appreciate how much money is going
to flow from legalized gambling and you
know new york came online this week with
mobile betting and they've made a ton of
money already as more and more states
come on board the money keeps going up
and up how do you make more money for
the nfl and the nfl players association
you increase inventory you add another
game and then i think they're going to
start adding teams it's not going to be
any time soon but i think as they
understand how much money can be derived
one game at a time one week at a time
they're gonna they're gonna want more
they're gonna want to give us more so
there's more stuff people can bet on i
was thinking about this
um
i think you were on the plane it might
have been a red eye coming back from
denver
and we were seated next to somebody
affiliated with the nfl who said ask me
any questions you want
and at the time i wanted to know about
adding an extra playoff team and if we
would be adding a 17th game well he said
at the time the person i'm talking to
we're going to be adding that extra
playoff team
so that's seven years ago that next that
monday i come in and i said hey got a
reliable source
mike you were there with me
but i don't think you reported it and i
got put out there and all of a sudden
somebody said
the nfl said no that's not true and i
went i'll be damned i'm in trouble here
but it was the nfl who said hey ask me
any question you want
well i may have been asleep at that
moment or i would have reported it so
it's a long it was a long day yes it's a
long day and night and week in denver
but uh
they had wanted to expand the playoff
field for a while they wanted to expand
the season for over a decade the
challenge was getting the union to agree
to it and it was difficult to get the
players association to agree to a 17th
game
but money talks and the you know
that's that's what's eventually going to
get the union to agree to 18. they'll
come up with ways to make it safer
expand the rosters but it's going to be
more it's going to be more and you know
dan i don't know can they justify going
to 16 playoff teams half the league
maybe they can go to 16 if they have 34
teams maybe that's the key but i just
think it's a matter of time before
there's no buys there's 16 teams and
everybody plays
this opening weekend with eight games in
standalone windows instead of six i'll
leave you with this if the cowboys lose
this weekend
if the cowboys lose this weekend i think
what's going to happen is they're going
to strike some sort of a deal with their
offensive coordinator kellen moore like
they once had in place with jason
garrett to take over eventually for mike
mccarthy and eventually will be
whenever jerry jones decides it is
during the 2022 season depends on how
they do after the 2022 season during the
next season but i think they don't want
to let kellem moore get away because
other teams are going to be interested
they want to groom him to become tom
landry jerry jones tried to do it with
jason garrett and maybe waited too long
with jason garrett before giving up i
think they're going to try to do it
again with kellen moore so that's the
balance here i don't think mccarthy gets
fired but i think they're going to
mobilize to make sure that they can
transition from mccarthy to kellen moore
the same way they transition from wade
phillips to jason garrett i lied i have
one more if matthew stafford doesn't
play well this weekend well
well you know
they're not stuck with him contractually
like they were with jared goff but i
mean think about this a year ago what a
big deal it was two first-round picks a
third round pick
and jared goff for matthew stafford and
someone explained it to me recently you
know what when you look at matthew
stafford playing
the trade actually was two first round
picks a third round pick and jared goff
for jared goff
because how are they any better off than
they were with jared goff the way
matthew stafford played eight touchdown
passes eight interceptions the last four
games
i think if they go
uh
one and out and that's it and they lose
on monday night
you know
sean mcvay will say all the right things
but we know from his time with jared
goff what he thinks what he believes and
what he says are two different things
and at some point we know that vibe
they're all in they're always looking to
get better they're always looking for
the bright shiny object i could see him
fall out of love with matthew stafford
as quickly as he fell out of love with
jared goff i lied i had one more is ben
roethlisberger retiring or just retiring
from the steelers
i think he's done i think he's done and
he knows he's done although who knows
hey hey you know you win a super bowl
you know
not that they will but you get
rejuvenated i just he can't play like he
used to and he finally realized he can't
play like he used to and and what he
if we would rank all 32 starting
quarterbacks top to bottom
he'd be pretty damn close to the bottom
right now and that may feed into their
narrative this weekend and so be it if
it does but but if you would go through
quarterback by quarterback and
prioritize one over the other he would
be very very close to number 32.
who would be beneath
ben roethlisberger on that list
uh well you know it's hard to say with
the guys who just have one year it's
hard to say like do you put you don't
put a trevor lawrence down there do you
but i mean think about who would you put
what starting quarterback think of one
starting quarterback who wasn't a rookie
this year that you would say arnold
what darn but but is he even a starter
right now you know jimmy garoppolo is
down in that category as much as 49ers
fans don't want to admit it uh he can
execute handoffs extremely well and he
did play well against the rams with the
game on the line i'll jared jared goff
jared goff's down there jared goff's
down there you know even though he he
beat the cardinals somehow and had three
touchdown passes in that game but you
know it's easy to say oh a top 10
quarterback top ten quarterback once you
start rattling off names you get into
the 20s pretty quickly and there's some
guys making a lot of money that are down
in the 20s and you know some some
potential hall of famers that are
creeping down toward 32. so i think
ben's sufficiently self-aware
that that it's over
and and i think the way that it ended
this year storybook already
you don't want to disrupt that by
starting a new story with another team
now i'm officially done with you mike
thank you thank you bye thank you that's
right mike florio pro football talk live
show that precedes hours on peacock